religion politics and the power of
poetry in the interview the poet and
liberation theologian enesco cabin i
Nesta Carter now thanks for joining us
at DW here in Germany you've been
awarded the tear or Vanar prize for
cultural dialogue what does this mean to
you oh wait me parece el premio muy
importante porque I think this prize is
very important important figures have
won it before me well-known individuals
who deserve it much more than I do what
have you written me my achievements are
more modest of you and therefore I am
more grateful for this award I mean
typical Margaret rule 40 people ustedes
but when it comes to the Catholic Church
and its future your voice carries
particular weight lately we heard that
in your eyes Pope Francis is a
revolutionary can you explain that
evolución re o como se splick I so go
ready did I say that I don't remember
but it's true yoga think what he's doing
is a revolution his style is not
revolutionary but rather more cautious
and yet that is what he's doing in the
Vatican a revolution in the church and
in the world nobody got oh he's changing
everything nothing less than that Julian
mundo it's like a miracle no I'm here
there's the cambiando love but is he
really changing everything what we've
seen this year have been mostly gestures
but can deeds follow these gestures no
se puede quedar solo a noon ki about
eight pappadeaux eiffel difficult in
essence the papacy is nothing more than
that gestures and a lifestyle you this
Pope has decided not to live like a pope
read the la vida he doesn't live in the
papal chambers in his palace pop buddy
he lives in a modest guesthouse where
you get your food on a tray and eat with
others out there he doesn't even sit at
the head of the table da ba da de la
mera cree que en toda todo all this
means one thing a big change in the
church pero creo que ejemplo de but do
you think that Francis consent such a
powerful example that the church
hierarchy
follow him rawr kia de la iglesia lost
ahead yes it is a role model for many
and this certainly bothers more than a
few powerful individuals in the church
they voted for him but they can also
withhold their support from him yo
quiero lo puede seguir cree que la que
la la iglesia católica oh do you think
the relationship between the church and
groups like Opus Dei and the Legion of
Christ which flourished under Pope's
Benedict him John Paul the second you'll
be they ruled the church ever associates
that now over oh you look at the moment
yes well but who knows that maybe they
will soon crawl out of their holes or
either but for now they are keeping
quiet in a junk al que el cual sera el
instrument which attempt should Francis
take to implement the reforms he wants
to make in the church reform s que
quiere la iglesia ellos ave he knows
which one when he took office I felt
that he must immediately convene a new
council the third Vatican Council yeah
Catherine and I think even now this
would be the right thing would you know
what to God wrote that but perhaps
there's an even deeper way to change the
church than a council because councils
have come and gone j/ki out that form
i'm a poor food icon got really hurt the
Second Vatican Council was completely
dismantled by the last two posts quote
Rio de gallo and a council should have a
substance that endures beyond the
lifetime of a pope money like a
decorator continue really critical to
Patil of what I think the church needs
more fundamental reforms yo creo que yet
there for but ok did he deliver
historian approval Francis is very
careful first he must change the Curia
and the Curia is very powerful it's
based on centuries a powerful their
Messiah de Lucas cardrona church
hierarchy and it's abuse of power what
needs to change in the church in social
terms in Latin America for example the
Catholic Church is still the largest see
is here but it's losing more and more
believers to the Protestant and
evangelical churches so what direction
must the church take meaning should the
be women priests should same-sex
marriage be allowed should the church
turn to the poor and adopt a more
progressive ideology David hacer cars la
iglesia a los pobres SI tambien a una
idea loggia mess pro racista so Mucha la
pregunta hey raro these are many
questions at once yo creo que lab later
I think that women should not only be
priests but also bishops and Pope's yo
creo que in addition the office of the
Pope should not be given for life after
global relief the pope is elected yeah
yeah 50 so it should also be possible to
unelected he your bro gecko hand I think
there are more fundamental issues no one
should be priests neither men nor women
that they grow the first Christians had
no priests for three centuries are you
bother the regulation here there was no
priesthood but what do they can we do
that that work in the third century just
before the corruption in the church
began with Emperor Constantine and the
church became a world power there was a
church father who said we have neither
priests nor temples nor altars in the
third century there were no temples via
the mass was celebrated in the homes of
believers hadaba that he would not let
on Blair larissa de preguntar let me
briefly when popes John the 23rd and
Paul the second were canonized did it
seemed appropriate to you to bring them
together in a single ceremony que las
papas to BSN juntos in a decade
apologetic the particular canonizing
John Paul the second seemed monstrous to
me d end one had supported this Mexican
priest cheviot eco de abeja Cano the
founder of the Legion of Christ yes yeah
I've said it yo the heck he was a
monster leupold to heal and for a pope
who protected and supported this man to
be canonized is just as monstrous
gatorade edible Bowl trophy cody KO Oh
Darryl usted ademas de porres oberto
destro car now as a poet and priest
you've devoted much of your life to Paul
Otis sanyo's day when Hugo Chavez ruled
in Venezuela you supported his policies
follow in the Bolivarian revolution its
browsers also applied to Nicolas Maduro
no fee per game I don't know it wasn't
known when I was in Venezuela we bid it
up since then I haven't been back to
Venezuela and I cannot believe what the
media say a little neither those who
defend him nor those who attack him I
can't judge Maduro there's a lot of
protest in opposition would I am well
both of your who is protesting the rich
students because the universities in
Venezuela were only for the rich Chavez
open them to all students I supported
chopped as his revolution but I love it
and for what's happened since then I
don't know the job look I got I would
have normally America laughter you see
Latin America right now as a single
block or is there more division
politically in tan bahama nestle that
deal bro I see Latin America as a block
because there is a second struggle for
independence the first was liberation
from the Spaniards the second from the
Yankee Empire this is what's happening
now da figueira no L Nicaragua
l'évolution personal que usted ha tenido
y política a CEO your personal and
political development and Nicaragua was
dominated by dramatic upheavals he
donated with it it which pitcher would
you draw a President Daniel Ortega back
when you two were close how do you see
him today oh guess that's with Eddie and
Laura what if what do you want to know
what do you think of Daniel Ortega
giladhiz a dictator its sole rule by one
family he is wife and his children these
are the only ones who have any say in
Nicaragua there's not one minister who
still dares to say anything that's the
situation there if they left it really
got home does this have something to do
with ortega's personality daily
different with his and his wife's it's a
question of character or corruption they
also fill their pockets scandalously
well let me know if you look back at the
Sun and easter revolution
what do you think was wrong been a que
salio mal Palo Alto everything it was a
very beautiful revolution for me and for
many others it was the most beautiful
revolution that has ever happened it
welcomed by affection and solidarity
throughout the world throughout the more
than 10 years it lasted could William O
did it would fuel it failed because of
the interference of the United States
because of that all the people voted
against the revolution of we're in
Andhra Reagan and later the first
president Bush got their way politically
there a young lady people and when the
Sandinistas lost the election they also
lost courage and some of them not all
but some of the most important leaders
of the revolution began to fill their
pockets scandalously before they handed
over power to the new government yeah
gurudeo no todo pero a guru that
destroyed the revolution in patrol art
American Dorota meant and since then we
have continually moved away from the
best of what this revolution offered
deportable mucho de go Ruby her good
caviare Volodya papo de da de de lecrea
preguntar mu rápidamente ya casi i want
to ask you a series of very short
questions with a request for short
answers I'll say the names of some
politicians and have you tell me your
opinion on them first off barack obama
in primero is barack obama went before a
lot doctor he has disappointed me and i
think many in the united states and
around the world feel the same way we
believed in a miracle I will a black man
in the White House but it but it seems
that he has not achieved what many hoped
for from him da ba dee da riddim field
fidel castro but about you Roberto delam
barat for me he was a very impressive
personality don t i've written a lot
about him and always greatly valued him
he's really fascinating but i don't
agree with his current support the
Nicaraguan government I think it's
unethical to do then que me parece que
poco 80 go yasir low angle on gamma
miracle American no I can't say we
that's very far away leonardo boff a
great man a great theologian and
ecologist a visionary of theological
ecology or ecological theology yo yo yo
lo VI por if you didn't finally Ernesto
Cardenal did about Francis of Assisi as
much as a man is before God that much he
is nothing more just out of curiosity
why did you start to wear your hair long
for okay but again i don't remember they
i was young when the age of revolutions
began with long hair and beards i like
the long hair and they wear a beret so
my hair doesn't fall in my face not to
imitate Che Guevara nobody betta k jana
an international Carter now thank you
for joining us on GW thank you what